get up get up we're going to florida
hey dobby you ready to drive 16 hours
quick jacob get dressed all right
downstairs
16 hour drive and we're doing it one day
baby
well we are driving 1 000 miles from our
home
in northern virginia down to southern
florida
we're going python hunting iguana
hunting
spear lion fish we're gonna fish for
knife fish
spear tilapia try to catch barramundi
peacock bass armored catfish
and a whole lot more so are you guys
ready to be in the car for 16 hours
yeah travel montage
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
16 and a half hours later we made it
but i gotta get some kids to bed i will
see you guys in the morning
[Applause]
well good morning and welcome to cape
coral florida we're here in a four
bedroom
rental house with its own private pool
private water access and its own dock
and this thing costs less than putting
our family in a marriott hotel
so you know not a bad deal at all but
most importantly it's got internet
access because our kids are still
in school but our school district is
doing online school
so we thought why not just do online
school down here in florida
oh that's nice that's heated this canal
right out here in front of the house
gets us access to the gulf of mexico and
we can go and rent a boat and tie it up
right there we've got two weeks
full of awesome activities but today is
sunday so we're going to take it easy
keep it low-key and do online church
but monday i'm taking the entire family
down to the everglades
and we're going to be hunting all sorts
of crazy invasive species
well it is 6 30 in the morning and are
you guys ready to go python hunting
[Applause]
yes
all right guys we're here with captain
bill and south florida fishing and
hunting charters
me and the whole family are going to go
hunting pythons oscars
anything invasive that crosses our path
is in deep trouble
oh how about you take a seat so the name
of the game is covering as much ground
as possible we're looking for a snake
that's anywhere from six feet to 14 or
18 feet these things
are big and if we see any other invasive
species along the way
we're going to do that too
big alligator all right we're just
cruising down the bank
and we're keeping our eyes open for a
big long
dark brown snake sunning itself
we just saw a big old iguana which is
another invasive species
people keep pet iguanas they let them
loose and now there's breeding
populations
here in florida and they're just crazy
so we're going to shoot one
and we're going to eat it up
[Music]
look at this all right
these iguanas love to eat flowers fruits
eggs and they just
tear up the the native stuff all the
different invasive species that we catch
on this trip
we're gonna cook them up and eat them so
we're gonna be trying a lot of freaky
food
on this trip i want to eat the
waterfalls
back in the 90s when hurricane andrew
hit there was a reptile breeding
center that had a ton of burmese pythons
in it that got destroyed by the
hurricane and all the little pythons
escaped and that's why we have such a
massive python problem
but also you get people releasing the
reptiles into the wild that's how we get
the iguanas
you'll see occasionally ball pythons and
even a few anacondas have been caught in
here
and they've had such a huge effect on
the environment it is really rare to see
any small mammals
and a lot of the bird population and
even the alligators
get eaten by pythons because pythons
will eat anything they can put
their mouth around
hey tommy i saw some big oscars back
there you guys want to poke some fish
yeah yep
oh
[Music]
hearing this clearing see him right
there
got him
that's a good sized one
look at that see look he got the big red
dot on his tail that's
an oscar when i was a kid this was like
the popular
aquarium fish to have they're super
aggressive
they're like piranhas but without the
teeth they get
a little bit bigger than this there you
go and can i put it
blind pigs and acorns baby
we're not even halfway through our first
day of this two-week adventure and we've
got
two invasive species in the cooler
that's for sure
good shot at everybody from alaska to
about three years ago i went on a
burmese python hunting trip
here in the everglades and we just drove
down these roads here
for miles and miles and miles and we did
it at night with spotlights
it's all about just covering as much
ground as you can
oh my goodness oh those are big old
cichlids right there too
we're gonna see if we can't get some
tilapia or oscars here
i love this spear i hand forged it from
a piece of leaf spring steel
and the handle is made from ipe which is
one of the hardest woods in the world
and i use it to spear snake heads while
on a stand-up paddleboard
look
pretty good mom we have two fish in one
reptile shall we take it back to the
boat
well guys we didn't catch a python today
but that's all right we had
a ball but if you want to catch a python
you got to put some serious
hours in i've been on three python trips
and only seen one
but the action's not over yet i'm gonna
go on two more charters here with
southern florida fishing and hunting
charters
uh tomorrow we're gonna go after some
iguanas we're gonna target oscars a
little bit more
and uh we might still yeah catch a
python
i love you becca and i love what you've
done with your hair oh my
a little a little wind a little
sunscreen you know
it does look really hot actually i'm
kind of digging that well you want to go
home now and play in the pool
yeah i bet you do
we're all playing in the pool
and uh there's a manatee right there oh
there's a couple
of them yeah look at that manatees
swimming right in their backyard
that's pretty cool
when your wife goes python hunting with
you in the hot sun all day
you need to make her dinner and bring it
to her by the pool
i thought you might want to snack on
this while i get dinner ready
you know what sounds good to me
hamburgers big
hearty gourmet hamburgers these bacon
and fried onion burger patties
[Music]
see the stem on this head of lettuce i'm
going to show you how to remove it
there you go
all right babe there's dinner guys have
you had a fun day
[Music]
all right guys i'm here in west palm
beach florida and i'm here with skeeter
which is the captain
and owner of south florida fishing and
hunting outfitters
and today we are going to be shooting
iguanas this is a really unique
experience
but also it highlights a big problem
here in south florida
and the government has now asked
homeowners
and to shoot them and kill them and
they're just really trying to do what
they can
to get those populations under control
because they are going
bonkers here but we're going to do our
part we're going to shoot some iguanas
and then we're going to take them home
and eat them and i'm excited to see what
happens
and joining us on this trip will be
drake the iguana dog
we're going iguana hunting guys
soon drink soon we will get the iguanas
hunting with dogs is like taking your
kids they're just so flippant excited it
makes it
so much more fun on safety
just make out we've been here 10 minutes
and we've already seen five iguanas
i remember a time when coming to florida
and seeing an iguana in the wild was a
rare thing
you look around for these iguanas and
you see one and then you start seeing
two
and three then four i mean they're just
seems like they're everywhere
oh i see them will it not come from
oh you could probably jam oh he got him
there we go oh see more in there
that dog's up in there three iguanas
come piling out
drake let's go boy good iguana dog
come here come here right here here here
good boy
good boy look at this
i think he looks like a dragon he's got
this flappy bit here and
little spines look at these
claws holy mackerel
you know hitting an iguana from this
distance when everything's still
is not too bad when the boat's going up
and down the wind's pushing us around
it's challenging there's a good one
right there where
right there on the banks
i'll tell you what guys this is
challenging but there are so
many iguanas around here we're just
seeing them everywhere
it's only the ones that hold still out
in the open that we're taking shots at
all right guys there's another invasive
species those are egyptian geese
the population of those are exploding
down here in south florida as well
one of the reasons why it's important to
keep the iguana population down is
because of their burrows
and you can see all up and down these
canals they're digging the burrows
which causes erosion and different
problems as well
so there's a couple guys up here with
long poles with nooses on it and these
guys are paid contractors that are
paid by land owners to come and remove
the iguana infestations just like you'd
pay an exterminator the difference
between us and them
is is i'm paying to do it and they're
getting paid to do it
[Laughter]
just in that one person's backyard
there's five iguanas i can see right now
six there's another one
so i mean they're just thick in here
oh there he is oh that's too high ain't
gonna make nobody happy
oh look at the side that fills the
cooler man well there you go another big
one
check it out got my iguana scars
all right there's a big iguana on the
bank over here
yeah i should have gotten closer
we're heading back to the boat ramp and
we just spotted another
invasive species check this out
see this gooey stuff these are snail
eggs those eggs belong to this giant
snail
called an island apple snail it's one of
four species of apple snails here in
florida
three of which are invasive including
this one and they're just
everywhere all of these pillars and most
of those rocks
have eggs on them just one of the many
many
invasive species here in florida
we're going to go ahead and skin these
iguanas and take them home and cook them
and i'm going to show you guys
how to cook up iguana curry like a pair
of frog legs right there
there you go nice little chunk of iguana
tail
and some iguana legs that was a load of
fun and honestly i'm anxious to try
these out and taste these things
but i'm gonna get home and tomorrow i'm
gonna be meeting
skeeter again to do more python hunting
and to try to catch a whole bunch of
invasive fish
hi guys
it's amazing how much better at swimming
they are after one day i mean they're
learning so
fast jacob can you snorkel show me
oh my goodness you guys want to see the
iguanas
yeah yeah look at this big bertha
that's uh one two three four five ten
iguanas that's gonna make a lot of
iguana curry
what an interesting day every time i
come down here to florida i learn
something new and see something new and
it's just amazing
oh
look
well the kids are in bed and i'm going
to make some banana
ice cream
just blend up bananas with melt no sugar
no nothing else and it just tastes like
banana flavored ice cream pretty good
oh it's getting late i've got to go in
the garage here and butcher up
a bunch of iguanas we got a whole bunch
of iguana meat in the fridge and i was
hoping to cook it up tonight but it is
way too late so
i'm going to call it for today and i'm
going to see you guys
in the morning
so once again we are trying to catch
some pythons
but along the way we're going to fish
for a variety of invasive species as
well
peacock bass jaguar fish mayan cichlids
oscars we're going to see what happens
can you see all them fish
before we really get into the python
hunt we're going to make a little stop
here and do some fishing
i've got a live shiner a bobber and an
alligator eyeballing me
now now there we go
oh my very first peacock bass look at
the cool colors
i thought his gills were bleeding and no
they just got this beautiful orange on a
gill plate
all right we're gonna put him back
now that right there is a great example
of some of the arbitrariness
of invasive species peacock bass they've
been here for a while
and they're really really popular with
sportsmen so
we set them go there's actually limits
on them and they're treated like a game
fish here
largemouth bass now you guys call them
black bass down here here in florida
this is a native species but a lot of
places in europe this is an extremely
invasive species that's causing a lot of
problems right now
oh god wait wait it's a garb yeah oh
look at this
spotted gar they've got teeth look at
the wicked teeth on these
this is a native species and look at the
teeth on them they're just
awesome this species of guard doesn't
get
too huge not like the 300 pounders you
see in
texas but it's a native fish that gets
hardly any love
there we go
man he isn't as big as i thought all
right
all right now oh good one
little beast so that's my first oscar
i've ever caught on rod and reel
he's got some chompers on them squeeze
hard
look at that that is a beautiful fish
all right
go ahead oscar
look he's gargantuan all right
car out get out i don't want them
underwater
[Music]
had a real big fish on didn't see it but
it made a big old splash
now we've got alligators coming over
oh
look at that look at that bullhead fat
look at the body on that thing he is so
stumpy
but these don't get much bigger than
that
the edge there we go nice
like crown on his head
alrighty
look at the knob on this guy's head
we got a bump on his head man we've only
been here a few minutes but we've hit it
hard
landed some awesome peacock bass some
oscars
but i want to catch a python so we are
going to go cruise up and down the
canals and look for some more pythons
see what we can find
me and skeeter sitting here talking and
one of the things that just keeps coming
up is how you don't
see small mammals anymore in the
everglades
the opossums the raccoons the rabbits
the squirrels
i mean that they're all gone
across that sink land we're coming down
this little canal and there are tons of
oscars and fish in here we're gonna poke
some fish here
okay while you're doing this i'm gonna
watch the banks
oh you should have smoked it did too
look at that that's a different
oscar that's well i have no idea what
species that is but that ain't local
ah look at all the fish slime these are
the slimiest things
hey man i'm gonna be honest dude
oh skeeter i had a great time thanks for
taking these yes sir
listen if you guys are in south florida
and you want to catch iguanas and
peacock bass and all this wonderful
stuff
check out south florida fishing and
hunting outfitters i'll put a link down
in the video description below
of course i forgot my fillet knife back
in virginia so i'm gonna do it with this
six dollar bait knife i found
well it is another beautiful day here
and the kids are doing their online
school
you liking school no making my kids do
online school while they're staring at a
beautiful sunny pool is a special kind
of torture that i devised just for them
but today i'm taking it easy and i'm
going to be cooking up the oscars and
the iguanas i am going to make seared
oscar on a teriyaki rice and i'm going
to make
tandoori iguana with a tikka masala
it's gonna be good
so
there we go blackened oscar over
teriyaki egg and rice all right we're
gonna eat together i'll go get myself a
bowl
we got some frozen grapes nice little
summer snack
[Music]
what do you think of the oscar it's
great you did a great job it's a good
white meat
it's a subtle flavor you want more
well i got the iguana marinating in the
fridge so for dinner tonight we're gonna
have tandoori
iguana and iguana tikka masala
so we'll see how that comes out but i'm
enjoying this
more fish
well it's taken until about 3 p.m but
i've gathered enough strength to go
fishing
on the west coast of florida around fort
myers and cape coral almost
every house seems to be on one of these
canals and there's always
fish in the canals if your canal is
closer to the bay you're going to get a
lot of sheep's head
mangrove snapper snook and tarpon if
your canal is further inland
then you're going to get a lot more hard
head and
gar and things like that we've rented
four or five different houses on these
canals here in cape coral area and every
time i've done it i've caught fish off
these docks it's uh it's usually pretty
decent fishing if you want to see some
videos on how to fish for sheep's head
off of canals like this
or how to fish and eat hardhead catfish
i've got videos on that i'll put links
down in the video description below
reel them in
that looks like a decent fish there tom
here pull it up pull that up
don't get careful there's a lot of hooks
this is a hard head catfish a lot of
people around here don't like them
because they have the spines on their
pectoral fins and dorsal fin
and if you get stuck by it hurts really
bad but
as you can see they put a real good bend
in the rod they're feisty little guys
well i've got to do a zoom meeting for
work here so tommy is going to watch my
rods
and man the camera while i'm gone thank
you daddy
and that's why my wife was on board with
it you know she
well that was fun but i think i need to
get in the kitchen and start worrying
about dinner i've got some iguanas to
cook up
now you notice how my tandoori iguana is
not
red most of the restaurants add a little
bit of red dye
to make that really bright red barbecue
look on their tandori chicken
i just left it out because i really
don't care what color they are
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we got some tikka masala
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're a little nervous about it aren't
you i'm totally nervous
okay grab a plate and we will take this
journey
together okay
actually that's pretty good i can tell
it's if you over did this
it would get chewy in a hurry but i
think i got lucky
and i didn't overcook it but they have
tailbones no
this is the tail do you like the iguana
yeah but
it's like okay but when you dip it in
and then dip it in the rice it tastes so
good
so you like the curry but you're not so
sure about the iguana meat yeah
the guano legs i cooked in the pan are a
lot chewier than the ones i cooked in
the oven so
you know learned a little something
there so not overcooking it appears to
be a big deal
but you know still good though oh that
was pretty good
but i need to go and pack the car
because me and nathan are taking off
tonight
to meet a guide first thing tomorrow
morning to go
spearing tilapia
all right buddy you ready for a long
drive
your destination is on the right
i'll see you in the morning
me and nate are here with byron and his
wife kim
and they're with osceola outback
adventures and they are going to take us
out spearing tilapia now they normally
do bow fishing charters
but uh hey i've got a seven foot spear
so you know
i'm gonna do that peacock bass look at
that spear holder just
just begging for a spear oh this area is
beautiful
we are hunting tilapia this fish is
native to africa
and it's an invasive species that's just
all over here
in southern florida and a lot of places
in the south and north america it's
really common for people to farm tilapia
and they just kind of spread all over
the place they're a little bit harder to
catch on rod and reel because they tend
to eat more like algae and plankton and
stuff but
uh they definitely take a spear okay
yeah they'll they'll eat the spear
every time they're gonna be big and
white like you'll see them glowing
the real limitation with the spears you
got that distance and that distance
makes a big difference so
i'm going to i'm going to earn my
tilapia okay here we go
look at that first throw definitely
aiming low enough
well first through of the day and we got
ourselves a massive tilapia
that's a streak i probably can't
maintain but look at that
oh
okay i guess that wasn't a tilapia good
shot though
there we go look how pretty those are
oh yeah you see it just you just see it
plowing
that is a perfect kill shot right there
oh yeah look at that we got clam
look promising didn't it oh yeah
fast on your feet
oh that sounds
oh i think i lost my my wingman here
too hard guys i'm having such a good
time and i've seen so
many tilapia they're just huge probably
seen a hundred fish
on this short trip but we're gonna go
try another spot that has another type
of invasive species
called an armored catfish and we're
going to try to spear some of those as
well
you want a spear an arvind catfish buddy
yeah come here come here
see do you see that dark fish right
there ready
there's a lot of different species of
armored catfish but they come from south
america
and they eat mostly decaying wood oh
here it is this one's shallow you this
one's all you nathan come here come here
see him see him put your hand on the
spear come on piano sphere
okay now throw it down throw it down got
him
i think you might oh
he blakeled us so they'll build a cave
put an egg mass in there it looks like a
big yellow sponge
and they'll lay their eggs in there and
then they protect the front of the hole
by guarding it with a you know big
armored catfish so you reach up there
and you can
catch that catfish by hand and pull them
out and then when you reach in about
elbow or
bicep deep you'll feel that spongy mass
you can pull it out
the tropical fish farmers here in
florida will
actually buy those and put them in their
hatchery and hatch them to sell the
little sucker fish plecos in the
aquarium trade
that's where they go there's commercial
placo kidnappers yes exactly
oh nathan right here right here big
placo oh my god
yeah yeah the trophy placo placosaurus
that's what that is you ready nate
okay go get him
i know you got him what you got him see
here
you ready yeah pulled up pulled up
oh you pinned him i i don't think we
that even pierced him
sorry that was a heavily armored placo
okay
you ready you ready now oh we got him
oh that is insane no wonder they are not
afraid of us
nathan does that make you want to just
get him even more
we need to activate beast mode
now that we got beast mode activated i
think we can do this
i can see what's going on here we need
to we need to touch things up a little
bit
okay come here nate this one's deep but
we can get him right there see where my
spear's pointing
yeah okay that's where you one two three
go
look at him look at that that's big
that's much bigger than the ones we
caught
this right here is an armored catfish
native of the amazon
they're really popular in aquariums and
of course
people let their fish go and they're
just
all over the place and there's a couple
different species but you can see
they're cool little mouths with the
little brushes in there they eat algae
and
rotting wood and things like that all
armored all over
yeah okay you want to try to eat them
neat yeah
i do here's one in the water come in
here on the nose have it down
you got them
we could spend days in here chucking the
spirit things but we got a little more
surprises
left in store
[Applause]
now we're going to follow byron and his
wife to a lake that they own that
stocked
with north america's only population of
catchable
barramundi which is a very popular
sports fish in australia
and yes i am going to pronounce
barramundi three different ways without
any consistency whatsoever
nathan there's a giant tortoise on the
side of the road
whoa oh tommy is gonna be so jealous
now because he's a wild animal we're not
gonna touch him okay is that
cool or what that's the biggest tortoise
i've ever seen in the wild that's huge
that is so cool oh look at this nathan
those are love bugs they used to hang on
to each other yeah
look at this there's more love bugs see
look right there they call them love
bugs because when they mate they stick
together
and fly together as a pair but people
hate love bugs down
here because they get huge swarms of
them and then you smash them with their
car
and their body's guts are kind of acidic
and it eats away the pain in your car
and it's really hard to get off
oh man look at all the love bugs on the
windshield
oh there's so many bugs i love bug
attack
oh look at all these love bug guts oh
look at how many love bugs there are
stuck to the front of the car
and that was just from driving for 20
minutes that's crazy
well yeah we got our guide mike here
who's getting me all rigged up so i can
use my
catfish and carp signature series rod
here i'm excited to try it out on some
barramundi and
this lake is full of barramundi which is
an australian fish that gets up to 100
pounds in the wild
but here we're looking at anywhere from
just a couple pounds up to 20 pounds
they're supposed to be an incredibly
hard fighting fish throw it out and
start reeling it back at steady retrieve
and if they don't hit it that way you
then try to work a little bit
a little bit yeah give it a try dude
grab it right up here
there you go oh he's here
oh
good job nathan
look at you connor one way before me
sharp right in there
you can go down but you come back up and
just barely feel it sharper the ring oh
jeez yeah you can see your face
guaranteed
smile
nathan high five you ready for another
one nate speaking of invasive species i
just got
bit by a fire ant which is another
invasive species from south america i
believe
but they're all over here in florida
oh do you see the splash your bait made
yeah
watch it and then what will happen is
when the barramundi come
it'll explode oh good pop there nate
i'm just the cameraman
just hold it for real still oh there you
go get in there
sit there look
number two nate turn them sideways
hey nathan was that cool awesome
oh nate you gotta hit
oh that might be the biggest one you
caught so far but
nathan look at that chunk that feels
like 11 pounds 12 pounds something like
that maybe
that is a monster
look at that what a fighting fish that
thing was all sorts of jumping
oh beautiful hard fighting fish
jumps like three four feet out of the
water crazy
well mike thank you so much that was
just an absolute blast
anytime it's our pleasure nathan
outfished me he outfished me good
we had a great time spear fishing in the
morning and catching barramundi in the
afternoon
if you guys want to come down in florida
and do this check out osceola
outback adventures i'll put a link down
in the video description below
it's a great time you ready to go home
and see mama yeah yeah all right let's
do it
look at this nathan we got some sandhill
cranes
when i was a teenager we used to hunt
those up in alaska and they're actually
a very tasty bird
well it's hard to see through all the
squished love bugs but i think we just
drove
past a turkey here that's turkey
that took a lot of work to get those off
one tilapia filet and i can't get over
how huge these tilapia are
they're just a massive fish these
armored catfish
are very armored but they're a little
bit soft on the underbelly
[Music]
all right so there's a big piece of meat
and there's a big piece of meat
on the army catfish
well the boys are fed into bed and becca
is off at the airport
picking up my sister who just decided to
fly down from alaska to join us
and we're glad to have her so they
should be showing up at any minute hi
melanie
[Music]
it is a wonderful relaxing day today i'm
just sitting here
catching up on some editing because your
appetite for videos is insatiable
the mating dance of the melanie is
bizarre
in its ritual and very unsuccessful
i'm gonna run to the bait shop and uh
get myself some live pin fish
and uh we're gonna try doing a little
fishing while we at it
all right guys i got a little bit of an
unusual rig here i've got
a three ounce egg sinker above
a float and then below that i got a
bunch of leader
and a circle hook all right
there we go got the lead anchored on the
bottom got my float out there
and even though it's super windy it'll
just kind of stay out there and do its
thing
we'll just let that sit for a little bit
[Music]
this is turning out to be a lovely day
just sitting here
editing by the pool watching my fishing
rod tips
little catfish hold on tight yeah it's a
feisty
fish
another catfish
another hardhead catfish
i've been editing becca and melanie went
out and got barbecue
holy mackerel southern style egg rolls
who wanted the grilled cheese pulled
pork tater tots
and we've got ribs nope but real
lemonade doesn't have
tom are you enjoying your food yep
oh our bellies are full the kids are to
bed
and i am back at it editing videos
i'll see you guys tomorrow morning
it's a lovely sunday and mother's day
and we are just doing some online church
today
i'm gonna make lunch for mama and i am
going to make
garma marsala sweet chili sauce
tilapia burgers well bad news guys some
of my video files got corrupted and i
lost the footage
of me seizing the tilapia fillets and
cooking the armored catfish if you want
to see how i cook and eat
armored catfish check out the video
description for a link to a previous
video where i did just that
as for the tilapia fillets i seasoned
them with salt
with pepper and then orange zest and
garment marzala
[Music]
oh my goodness this looks delicious
it's nice because everything's not over
seasoned you know tilapia is such a
subtle fish
it's really easy to overpower it
you like that oh yeah
we're just finishing up lunch and uh
osprey joined us
[Music]
for mother's day my wife really wanted
to go on a drive
so we're gonna do that
well for mother's day becca really
wanted a cute picture of all the boys
smiles
look at me look at me get in you can get
the first kindle flick are you happy
i had a great time um all right grab
your stuff let's head out to the car
all right grab all right we're going to
the florida keys for another
invasive species we are going spear
fishing
for lionfish
this looks pretty awesome yeah look at
that the ocean's right there
let's go get some food
in the tree yeah there's an iguana right
there
there's iguana right there
we're never gonna make it to the
restaurant the boys keep spotting
iguanas
we've got conch fritters come from a big
sea snail
i mean i love that one kind of like a
corn fritter if it had octopus instead
of corn
i like it
all right guys it's bedtime everyone get
to sleep i'll see you in the morning
heavy pontoon boat morning morning
welcome to the key yeah luke jeff good
morning good to meet you yeah you got it
excellent
all right here we are with forever young
spear fishing i've got captain jeff
and i've got tony young here and they
are going to take us out snorkeling
and looking for lionfish hey thomas you
excited
i haven't been spearfishing underwater
since i was a teenager and i absolutely
love it so i'm excited
to get a chance to do this again and uh
i've always wanted to spear lionfish so
this is
this is gonna be cool
oh my goodness look how clear that is oh
look i can see fish right there see you
we thought this would be the perfect
spot for you guys to hop
in get your gills wet i'm about to jack
up the light exposure on my lips
time to get the lady views
[Music]
and this is how you lose 1.5 million
subscribers
right now because we're in a special
protected area only certain permit
holders can spare
invasive lionfish and that includes mr
young
so if we see any lionfish here he's
gonna spear them
but after we go and snorkel around here
let the kids have some fun we're gonna
go try some other places where i can get
a chance to spear some lionfish
yeah this is how we this is how we catch
the fish we stick your diaper down in
the reef and all the fish float to the
top
all right guys you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you want to see a cleaner fish cleaning
a barracuda like six of them
whoa watch out for you have fun yeah i
swam with them i literally got close to
them and they didn't attack me they were
like
hello hey jacob did you have fun
say click subscribe
neither do you need a pee yeah do you
know how you pee in a wetsuit hell
you just pee your pants you ain't cool
unless you pee your pants maybe you guys
need to go pee
come on
just beat their pants raise your hand
yay
i think it's time to go look for some
lionfish i want to go poke a fish
tell me you like the feedback
so we had fun doing a little bit of
snorkeling now it's time to knuckle down
and do some serious
lionfish hunting now lionfish are an
invasive species from the
indian pacific ocean area so they're all
over from
southern japan to australia to the
philippines they've been
let loose here and they're just all over
they're an invasive species here
in the caribbean gulf of mexico area and
over in the mediterranean
so we're gonna hunt the lionfish using
these three prong hawaiian spears
and uh they're really simple easy to use
so even i might be able to spear one
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you sad to be leaving this spot yeah
she will go to a new spot okay
[Music]
that's so cool
got
well i missed my first lionfish all
right we're just gonna go try another
spot
go try to poke another fish
oh
so
so
so
[Music]
oh my goodness okay i dubbed down there
and i nicked him
and he took off to a separate coral head
and we're gonna see if we can't find
them over there
luckily these things don't run very far
i shot him again this time we're gonna
try to get him
[Music]
okay i shot him a third time we got him
on the prongs
but you need to really work him out of
that hole and it's just too hard
so mr young is gonna go down there try
to get him out of that hole
[Music]
there he is got about six bullet holes
in him and his spine's right there oh
yeah yeah no
whoa nice shot
oh what a great trip even though we only
got two fish i'm super jazzed because
normally
they do this with scuba gear it's a real
challenge to to get this
snorkeling but we did it
oh i appreciate that thank you so much
that was such a great time
what was your favorite thing you saw
fish
[Music]
i got to tell you the bottom looks
really far away when you're up there at
30 feet of water you're like daddy's
like
oh wow doing everything you can decide
we caught the lionfish now we're going
to show you how to clean them these are
a
venomous fish if you get stung by their
venomous spines
it hurts like a bee on steroids from
what i hear
it doesn't feel good so not in there
yeah so there's no spines here
no spines there you have one you can see
right there they've got oh i see they
got right like a catfish right there and
then a couple on the anal fin
okay and then everything up on their
door so all the dorsal fins when you get
stuck and that flush gets pulled back
the grooves are exposed and the venom is
able to leave the spine
gotcha so the longer the spine and the
farther it goes in the more venom can
get into your system oh
you ever been spined i have been stuck a
couple
how bad was it uh for me it's usually
not too bad i might have built up a
tolerance over time but for most people
you know if you get in your finger the
whole hand will swell up about twice the
size
look there's a man oh hey manatee that's
our buddy steve
hi steve he uh he now eats lionfish
carcasses
it's a flesh-eating manatee oh that's so
hardcore
steve oh and there's a nurse shark right
there
so they all know our boat they're ready
for their dinner to fillet these what i
do is i just
pull their pectoral fin back make a cut
there
and then i'll hold the entire body of
the fish using just the tip of the knife
going very slow and careful so you can
see that whole time i'm just basically
keeping my hand in the same position
yeah trying not to move very much and
that's oh that looks gorgeous that's the
prized meat that's why lionfish is so
delicious
and the skin's not too bad looks like
you can probably just fry it up and eat
the skin you can yeah yeah
hold on look at that there oh there he
goes
there he goes oh he just ate he just ate
it
that manatee just ate fish flesh so
he'll eat it spines at all
like um you know they kind of it just
seems like they kind of chew on i don't
know if they're getting like the
moisture out of the fish
or what they are but they seem to play
with it for quite a while
nice and tight okay all right now drop
it right right in front of steve
lusting manatee oh he's just totally
sucking that down
steve you're my favorite manatee ever
man thank you very much you're welcome
you're right thank you thank you it ate
a ton of meat but there you go
some little teeny tiny lionfish fillets
and we're going to take these home and
cook them up
is this a shirt yeah
you like that it says forever young
spear fishing yeah
we had such a blast this is one of the
best trips
i've had in a long time i really
appreciate it yeah it was amazing trip
thank you so much for coming out with us
listen if you guys are in the florida
keys and you want to do spear fishing
snorkeling scuba diving
rod and reel fishing whatever check out
forever young charters
with tony and jeff here and they will
hook you up guys i'm going to put links
down in the
video description below their website
and social media accounts so check that
out
thank you thank you great having you
guys on board oh we had such a great
time
after swimming in the salt water and all
the hot sun
ice cream sounded like the perfect thing
becca got key lime sorbet
and then melanie got a slice of key lime
pie
dipped in chocolate frozen on a stick
that hit the spot
way down
hey good morning guys
i am walking gently i am walking
gingerly
but i am walking oh
oh i'm gonna get some stuff to cook up
that lionfish and
i'm gonna get a little extra seafood to
go with it and we are gonna have a
wonderful
seafood lunch today all right we got
island seafood market near pine island
here
and it really backs up right to the
marina
oh good fresh seafood
hey becca i've got something for you
who's got two thumbs and loves key lime
pie
this lady all right while the kids are
doing online school i'm gonna cook up
some lionfish
and some jumbo shrimp and some lane
snapper
and conch fritters it's we're gonna have
a great lunch
here i'm gonna show you some cool
recipes
we got some naked mango juice this
stuff's nice and thick
and we're gonna reduce it in a pot till
it becomes a wicked awesome
mango sauce
[Music]
that's why tonight
hmm
[Music]
all right we'll just cool that sauce
down it'll be ready in just a few
minutes
[Music]
there's the lane snapper
coconut crusted lionfish and some prawns
looking nice good it's a lionfish
here mango sauce here
and we're just gonna go and drizzle that
on the coconut crusted fish and shrimp
with the lane snapper i fried it on the
bottom then finished it off in the oven
and it gives it that nice crunchy
texture on the bottom without making it
too heavy and greasy if you fry the
whole thing
good really good oh the conch fritters
with mango chutney is good
would you rather try some of the
lionfish
[Laughter]
melanie what do you think of the
lionfish oh it's really good it's all
good
becca's living her best life here really
good
it's been a fun low-key day but i have
got to head into the car
to head three hours east to meet a
gentleman tomorrow morning about fishing
for clownfish also known as knife fish
an extremely fascinating invasive
species
apparently a major gas line was hit with
some sort of cyber attack
and i'm seeing some disconcerting things
on facebook in the news about people not
being able to get gas
well i've now passed five gas stations
and only two of them were open
we'll see what happens
i'm getting up at 6 30 in the morning
i'll see you then
pimples to the top i turned my phone on
after being off all night
and there's like 12 text messages from
becca and
some photos
i have no clue what happened but
apparently nathan cut his forehead open
and went to the er i'm texting becca to
find out what's going on but
she's back at the condo just barely
getting to sleep so
we'll just see
hey guys i'm here with captain patrick
smith with swamp to see guide service
here and we
are going to go out for knife fish also
known as clownfish also known as a lot
of different things but it is one of the
most unique
species that you can find here in
florida
well it's a beautiful early morning i
haven't yet started to bake
hopefully i'll keep from getting too
fried today
just saw a big gator we're cruising down
the canal and we see all these little
holes dug in the embankment and they're
caused by
nile monitor lizards which is another
invasive reptile from
africa quite large they're big
meat-eating
lizard they're not as prolific as the
iguanas and other invasive species but
they're they're
starting to get there so the state's got
game cameras and traps up here
trying to catch and remove nile monitor
lizards
did you do the bullseye snakeheads a
little clown knifefish just jump right
there are they a pretty finicky fish
like they're really sensitive to
timid because you're gonna pitch him
right up
reel down until your rod starts to bend
and set your hooks hard
wow look at that what a beautiful fish
that sucker fought like a champ too
jumped out of the air which i didn't
expect
look at that fighting that is
beautiful my first clown knife fish
let me show you something on them real
quick yeah sure you got teeth here yeah
teeth here teeth here and then watch the
top of the tongue
fangs right there on top of the tongue
oh my don't french kiss a clown fish
they drum and they swim backwards
they're pretty cool
that bent the rod really good i mean
those are a serious fish
we're gonna see if we can't do that
again
got wrapped around something sharp down
there that happens
well we are just about to move spots
anyways so we'll we'll try something
else
there you go
oh that's the males that get that big
knob on their head right sure is
first time i saw one of these i thought
it's gills were bleeding
and that's why they got the big bumps on
their head absolutely gorgeous fish
there you go what a pretty fish what a
nice little map
number two
well we hit this spot pretty good we're
gonna try another spot real quick
oh there we go it's gotta happen you're
bouncing off the gun
there we go nice little black crappie
this is a native fish i believe
all right look at that look at that
wiggle
all right got some fish we're going to
try another spot
we got this big ficus tree that's
dropping berries and uh
there's big old grass carp hanging up
underneath it eating the berries as they
fall down
they get up to a hundred plus pounds
they're huge fish they're from asia
and uh they're also called an amur carp
people breathe them and genetically
alter them to be infertile and stock
them
but uh they get loose sometimes
oh yeah they got a little iguana up
there man there there are a lot of them
around
putting little live shad there in this
little chum bat
flinging it out there just kind of
getting everyone excited same techniques
we use in carp fishing
to get some pressure off the largemouth
large mouths are a lot easier to catch
that's a hybrid strike bass
also not a native fish but this one is
deliberately stocked
it kind of seems like certain fish will
kind of get popular and fish and game
will go and deliberately stock them and
you know sometimes it's a good idea
sometimes it's not and
oftentimes it's very debatable hey babe
how you doing
how's nathan doing he looked so happy in
his little er photos
hold on just a second
nice little peacock bass i finally
talked to becca and got an update about
nathan and he fell out of bed
and caught his forehead on the
nightstand and cut it open
at one in the morning apparently
nathan's doing great he thought going to
the er was super fun
and stuff but poor mom was stranded at
home without a car and i had the first
aid kit in the back of my car and so
but she uh she got a taxi got him to the
er and he's all glued up and
doing online school happy as can be
oh we got a double here peacock for me
largemouth for you
there we go double trouble
just got a big ball
[Music]
he went and blew up on it missed it came
back got himself
pierced it's a bail fat peacock bass
that's why they make bad aquarium uh
largemouth bass just the biomass in
these florida waters is just amazing
big boy yeah they are beautiful and
solid thick one
oh a nice little channel catfish i don't
mess with cats
adios 15 pounds
a little wiper
let's take these good
beautiful fish well i completely lost
count of how many fish we caught but
it's probably close to 20 and a half an
hour
just spot is non-stop but i really want
to catch another clown fish
so we're gonna go try some other spots
where maybe the bass aren't as thick so
we got a better chance at targeting
specifically
clown fish you know that rule about you
never leave fish to find fish
i live to break the rules
don't eat my bait i think i've seen
probably 12
or 15 rides since we got here they're
just everywhere that looks right
oh that was so weird he was facing right
at me
and just back straight up net because
they're backwards swimming
they avoid the net oh that is so crazy
they can move in weird directions
there we go nice that is a big fish
that looks a little bigger than the
other one that is such
a cool fish they just ripple in the
water
look at that
what a cool fish i i just didn't expect
them to be such
aerial fish i mean they just love to
jump out of the water
that's cool well that was fun but it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to know
that i should probably go home and help
my wife out
hey thanks patrick i really appreciate
it thanks again for coming hey listen if
you guys want to go fishing with patrick
here and catch clown fish and build
peacock bass and whatnot
i'll put his guide service website and
information down in the video
description so make sure to check that
out
if you're down here in florida we'll
want to catch some clown fish
for christmas all right
we gotta get heading home and help becca
out she has had
a rough day all right three hour drive
back to cape coral
[Applause]
where's my boys oh
my goodness can i see your forehead
buddy you know what that phone is
just like a harry potter squad you lost
a tooth as well did you knock your tooth
out
i'm worried about you
it's been a long day so we're sitting
down to some cute food we got ropos
viejas got some fried plantains and the
frios negras
and all sorts of fun things
it's a busy saturday morning and we're
scurrying around cleaning the rental
house as quick as we can
to get out of here and hit the road it's
been an
awesome trip all right goodbye melanie
we'll see you guys did you have a fun
trip
16 and a half hour drive here we come
i said tell me your story
[Music]
it's actually a little bit chilly i
haven't felt cold in two weeks
well we made it back to virginia safe
and sound and i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
as much as we enjoyed making it if you
guys want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning
and if you want to see more travel and
adventure videos like this check out our
travel and adventure video playlist
we've got some great stuff there thanks
for watching
have a great day if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching